what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel uh today I'm
gonna be be reacting to a girl who gave
her experience Marrying an average guy
um before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're gonna
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way in let's get started
um so this girl says high value men are
overrated in the femininity space Online
The buzzwords High value man and high
value woman are tossed around a lot we
tend to Value what men find attractive
because we know that we need to embody
at least some of those things in order
to attract an attractive quality man and
maintain a health she seems so sweet she
just seems like a sweetheart marriage I
receive tons of comments from women who
say that we shouldn't care about what
men find attractive and they'll
literally say and I quote you're
focusing on all this femininity stuff
but your husband will still it on you
and I bet I could get him to cheat on
you firstly I always think project much
and then I think okay well come back to
me in 30 years and tell me how that
worked out for you and then I promptly
delete the comment so I completely
understand why this so it's interesting
I have such nuanced views on cheating
okay but I actually don't think all men
cheat I think some men are very loyal
um I think there are men that don't
cheat in sexless marriages because like
men there are men that have a sense of
like Duty and respect and like honor and
just wouldn't do that but I do think if
you go for certain guys you should know
what you're getting yourself into that's
that's my opinion Community emphasizes
being of high value but I actually think
pursuing high value men is overrated
people of course have different
definitions of high value man but the
most prevalent definition I see online
is a guy just being an above average
earner with a high status that's
essentially how Kevin Samuels may God
have mercy on his soul and the red pill
manosphere Collective talk about there
is a big debate right now on what a high
value man is this is so funny that is
there is such a big debate high value
men in fact Kevin Samuels had six
specific factors that he used to qualify
a man as high value if you're a high
value man then you according to him have
to one make at least a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars a year to for at
least the past three to five years three
have group acceptance from other
high-value men for network with other
high value men five have the reputation
as a high value man meaning having your
income and Public Image linked and six
have utility meaning that you're useful
to others being a high value man in this
vein has very little to do with
character if a man makes a lot of money
what that essentially signals is unless
he's an nipple baby is that he's
competent he's disciplined he's a hard
worker and those are all of course
valuable traits I am not here at all
this say that you should want a man
whose incompetent undisciplined and lazy
and makes no money at all what I am
saying is that if you are an average
young woman in your 20s or 30s and are
looking for men in the same age group
there is an infinitesimally small chance
that you're going to find a man in your
age group who may thank you thank you
and this is why the simps are the worst
because the simps will tell women just
raise your standards and I have no
problem with women being picky like
genuinely I have zero problem but when
we're telling women that we're all gonna
win the lottery it's a bit disingenuous
because not everybody can win the
lottery and most people are normal and I
think a lot of people come at what I say
and act like I'm trying to say it in a
way that that's mean to women but in all
honesty I think I'm nicer than these
simps that lie to women every day and
tell them them that and and other women
honestly that lie to women and say that
we're all going to win the lottery when
it's just not the case most women are
going to have to work in marriage most
women aren't going to get to be
Housewives unfortunately
um and does a guy does an average guy
still deserve submission I would say yes
six figures let alone a wholesome man
who wants to be monogamous who makes six
figures the average 25 year old man in
the U.S at least makes forty thousand
dollars a year the average 35 year old
makes sixty thousand dollars a year and
this is probably before taxes only about
10 percent of men in the US at least
make six figures ten percent and you
better believe that most of those men
are not that young it takes time to get
that kind of income they're probably at
least 45 years old if not in their 50s
and unless you want to have a pretty
large age Gap marriage I'm talking 10 to
20 years which most people I have to you
know that would be a good question to
ask would you rather have a guy making
forty thousand in his 20 or a hundred
thousand in his forties or fifties I'd
pick the guy in his 20s my opinion
because it's like because my dad always
said this because the the red pill is
big on age gaps right and I spoke to my
dad about this but he said like women
live longer than men so if you have too
big of an age Gap you're going to live
the second half of your life alone for a
lot of it and you can't buy time don't
want because they want to experience all
this different seasons of life together
then you should probably consider more
regular so-called average men I see a
lot of women online pining after the top
not even 10 percent of male earners with
the top five percent men who make at
least two hundred thousand dollars a
year women who think that being with a
regular dude is settling and complacent
I am not saying that money is an awful
thing I'm not saying every height
earning man is unwholesome however if
money isn't made focused or the highest
goal then it becomes disordered if
you're a young woman who wants to get
married start a family while you're
still young and you want a man who's
also young then you should not base your
standards off of what the red pill and
manosphere Collective call high value
there is no mention of character the
mention of piety and if you do not take
those things into consideration then
there will definitely be pitfalls
firstly when you're with this kind of
powerful man there's a higher risk that
he's going to be unfaithful as he may
have a bigger ego and there's no
shortage of beautiful women who actively
want to be with him for the same reasons
and when a worldly man this is a really
base to take as beautiful women throwing
themselves at him being well I think
most men would have a hard time
beautiful women were throwing themselves
at him faithful to one woman is more
difficult and less enticing I'm not
saying these beautiful women are causing
men to sin when you sin it is entirely
your fault but there are more
Temptations surrounding high value men
which is why a man and in the manosphere
and red pill Collective weirdly try to
reason that it's not unethical for a
high-valued man to cheat or to have a
high body count so it's interesting
Kevin Samuels had a different
um the reason that the red pill and I'd
have to make a whole video on this why a
lot of red pill channels um will say to
sleep with a lot of women is it's it's
more of a response to women because most
women don't so the average age of first
marriage is like 28 to 32 roughly in
Western countries right and most women
at that age don't want a virgin and they
want a guy that's more sexually
experienced and the issue that guys are
getting into is that you know the women
that they're speaking to want a guy
that's more experienced so it's more of
like a response
um and it's also like an unequal
exchange of value that those men are
getting because the women aren't virgins
but yet they want their husband like
okay because traditionally the women
used to have to bring Purity youth
um in shape Etc like to the guys and the
men would have protection and
provisioning and the high value men are
bringing the protection and provisioning
but they're still not getting virgin
wives so in a way it's not an equal
exchange of value because the man is
supposed to comprise on his mating
strategy which is screwing as many girls
as possible and the woman isn't bringing
what she's supposed to bring to the
table so you know I I'm not pro cheating
I hate I hate I've spoken so much about
cheating they always misconstrue my
thoughts on it but I'm not pro cheating
I don't think cheating is good however
if you date Jason Derulo I think you
should expect to get cheated on that's
my opinion not saying most high value
men cheat but there is a higher
proportion of them cheating so even if
you do want to attract this kind of man
there is competition and even if you do
settle down with this type of man you
very well may not experience as much
peace in the marriage because you are
keenly aware of the fact that he has
many options who are more less throwing
themselves at him and that kind of thing
would bother even the most secure of
women so does this type of man give you
a lavish lifestyle status convenience
Financial Security and relief in Spades
but what about lasting intimacy peace or
a tight-knit family and hey I get it we
are women we value a man who can provide
for us with resources because we're the
ones who get pregnant and give birth and
therefore we want a man who can provide
for us so that when we get pregnant we
can focus on being pregnant and being
present mothers but the transient thrill
of being with someone of high value and
the exclusive material benefits that
they can offer you very well may narrow
the scope of your vision this intense
attraction ultimately comes from our
fallen desire to seek Security in the
world and not from God money is
ultimately just a tool to exchange value
a means by which we achieve our goals
and if money is our highest goal in
itself then our life becomes shallow and
we forget its meaning you also may not
have as intimate of a marriage with a
very high value man these kinds of men
are extremely ambitious and busy they're
total Hustlers I'm not yes oh my gosh
and this was okay when I first started
watching red pill content because again
my dad is a top one percent earner and
most of my brothers are too and the
thing that you're gonna get with these
guys is they don't have time for you you
are not the center of their world they
don't have time to treat you like a
queen or a princess or all that
they sell us they're busy and that is
the issue is they're selling us the
simps sell you a dream they sell you a
dream the simps are the problem we're
talking about celebrities even doctors
lawyers and lucrative business owners
work around the clock they are
constantly busy and they enjoy being
busy how often are they going to slow
down to be present with you and your
family they may view themselves being
pillars of a family and only a financial
sense they may think oh I'm providing so
much for you that should be enough when
in reality you are aching for more of a
connection and intimacy your children
are aching for a more present father who
isn't always texting clients on his
phone or always has to travel for
business personally I did not marry a
high value man according to Kevin
Samuels he does not meet all of the
criteria for being a high value man he's
high value to me but he does not have it
all figured out yet and that's fine most
oh she's so cute don't get their stuff
together financially for a long time
most men earn more as time goes on but
in their mid-20s most men are not very
high earners and that is okay it does
not mean that they are low quality and
that they don't deserve a good woman's
attention I do not want to make it sound
like I settled my husband is very
handsome he's incredibly bright he's a
very hard worker and he's financially
responsible and he loves me but he's not
an incredibly High earner and he does
not have a high status in that vein he'd
be pejoratively considered just a
regular guy by many people and while I
may lack a high status wealthy husband
he still gives me so much my husband is
an avid Gardener he's actually using the
backyard space to grow dozens of corn he
has a plethora of vegetables and finely
pruned fruit trees he can build just
about anything out of wood and whenever
something is leaking or broken he can
either fix himself yeah and that's okay
this is when the girls say they don't
need a man it's like or that the men
need to split the housework or whatever
all this it's like okay then
provide value in being able to fix
things do yard work and women don't
appreciate or value it and I'm sorry
there's some value in just having a man
around the house to to help you with
that but like women it's like we act
like we do so much by doing the dishes
like we have dishwashers we have roombas
it's not he knows exactly where to get a
good deal or or he'll learn how to do it
himself many high value men are so
caught up in the corporate world that
they couldn't even mow their own lawn
with this type of modest lifestyle
you're also not going to be distracted
by an excess of material things because
of an excess of money you'll experience
Sacrifice by perhaps needing to live
more frugally which will help you grow
spiritually you'll likely be more
grateful for what you do have plus many
younger average men are setting
themselves up for Success later in life
and will rise over time I also have a
pretty strong inkling that after women
get married to rich men and settle into
their lifestyle it just becomes typical
a lavish lifestyle doesn't seem all that
lavish when it's all you've experienced
for such a long time it just becomes
your new normal and you may end up
yearning for the kinds of things you
could have had had you focused Less on
finding a high value man as the
manosphere red pill folk Define the term
and focused more on finding a Godly Man
even if you had to settle for a more
modest lifestyle I am definitely not
here to invalidate positive experiences
that women have had with high earning
Men My ultimate point is that what's
truly important in a man is not his
status it's not whether he runs an
incredibly lucrative business or whether
he earned six figures what's important
is that he's a hard worker that he can
take care of you and perhaps your
growing family that he's repentant and
earnestly loves and respects you I know
firsthand how attractive lots of money
and status is but that emphatically does
not make a good husband if we remain
devoted to worldly things and enslaved
to our fallen desires then we're not too
dissimilar to those who completely
reject or ignore their femininity our
femininity then becomes a shallow
raiment whose only purpose is to live in
unappreciated luxury even in the Bible
it says no man can serve two masters for
either he will hate the one and love the
other or else he will hold to the one
and despise the other he cannot serve
God and the man Matthew 6 24. Mama means
riches and the worship of them so while
we desire our needs to be met and we
need to do our part every day God
Comforts us and instructs US behold the
fowls of the air for they so not neither
do they agree keep in order to gather
into barns yet your heavenly father
feedeth them are ye not much better than
me but seek ye first the kingdom of God
and his righteousness and all these
things shall be added onto you we must
also deeply consider why we even seek to
be married in the first place is that
for our own pleasure or for the sake of
our salvation and to glorify the Lord to
this end I recommend seeking Pious men
who likewise seek God first in all
things ultimately a devout Man Who quote
unquote merely provides a modest
lifestyle is not to be overlooked thank
you all so much for watching and
hopefully I'll hear from you in the
comments and we'll see she spoke more
about character than I've heard any girl
talk about on my show no she was great
she was such a sweetheart
um let me know what you guys think the
top three um character traits that women
should look for in a husband are in the
comments like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel I'll talk to
you next time